las autoridades francesas se felicitan
han matado a su principal objetivo en el
sahel el líder y fundador de la filial
del grupo estado islámico en la región
adnan abu walid el shaarawy quien
previamente fue miembro del frente
polisario y de al qaeda en el magreb
adnan abu walid al zarautz y jefe del
grupo terrorista estado islámico en el
gran sáhara ha sido neutralizado por las
fuerzas francesas se trata de un nuevo
gran éxito en el combate que llevamos a
cabo contra los grupos terroristas en el
sahel
adnan abu walid al saharaui es
considerado responsable de múltiples
ataques en la llamada zona de las tres
fronteras un territorio que abarca parte
de mali níger y burkina faso las
autoridades de francia aseguran que fue
el líder del estado islámico en el sahel
quien ordenó el asesinato de 6
trabajadores humanitarios franceses el 9
de agosto de 2020 una orden de ejecución
entre muchas longhini sesión silver
eagle mo la organización también atacaba
autoridades civiles y tradicionales en
el marco de ejecuciones públicas
sangrientas sounds
sistema chico filme al antón
sistemáticamente filmadas y dirigidas al
propio emir luces timón que ulises
estimamos que el estado islámico en el
sahel es responsable de la muerte de
entre dos mil y tres mil civiles desde
2013 y precisó que la gran mayoría de
víctimas son de confesión musulmana
son de confesión musulmana la duda es
quien sustituirá al líder al frente del
estado islámico del sahel o si el vacío
propulsar a la fuerza de al qaeda en la
región el ministro de exteriores de
francia pidió que las autoridades
estatales actúen para controlar el
territorio los hechos se producen en el
marco de la reducción de la presencia
militar francesa en el sahel anunciada
por macrón en junio el presidente quiere
que la intervención extranjera en la
zona esté asegurada por una alianza
internacional